hi guys it's Amy Schumer and today I'm
going undercover on the Internet this is
actually me let's start with Yahoo
describe Amy Schumer in one word oh man
there's 36 answers model next how do I
overcome the disappointment when someone
says they don't get Amy Schumer's humor
I don't know that's tough I think
there's no way to get over it I think
maybe you take like a year go to Nepal
and just walk why is Amy Schumer so sexy
that's a good question
I've often wondered that I think it's
genetics I go to the gym 10 times a day
I never eat food and um a lot of plastic
surgery and that's me
[Music]
so now that Amy Schumer is married WTF
is she gonna make jokes about I mean I
like the people just think you stopped
having sex when you get married I just
got married give me a [ __ ] second
Jake Wolverton and I call Amy Schumer my
best friend if we've never met it yeah I
see no problem with that
you're my best friend except I can't
pronounce your last name Kate mucus
mucus our Amy Schumer and Jennifer
Lawrence still friends remember when we
were somehow reminded every hour of
every day that they were now or not and
I actually want to know people like so
really rubbing their friendship in our
face but really we just like hung out
but people take pictures of her wherever
she goes so yeah I've got other friends
what about what about Rachel Feinstein
my best friend's Bridget Everett
Jessica Sapienza from Long Island
nobody's asking about her YouTube
do you tip well yes more than 15% yes
more than 20 sometimes yeah I mean like
when it's appropriate yes
oh geez I'm gosh I'm a bad tipper okay
okay I I cannot confirm nor deny that
Jennifer is a bad tipper because she's
also the friend who like will forget her
wallet
she'll call herself like a rich deadbeat
and she's like oh does anyone have any
money and we're like you are rich Jen
you know not that I don't have money but
I don't know Hunger Games money I never
want you know killed a robotic dog and
tried to eat nightlock but I'm sure she
chips well she's a woman of the people
but she's frugal she is frugal no
question she likes a bargain don't get
me wrong Amy's very talented but I
wonder if sex didn't exist would Amy
have any material that's a really good
hypothetical it's funny if anybody
really broke down my jokes
it would be about 10 or 15% about sex
but because it's a chick I think people
are still like mmm women aren't supposed
to enjoy sex like you just do it because
you wanna make babies and it's like no
we also would like to come I am TV
claims to have kept detailed journals of
every day of her life between ages 13
and 23 yes that is true
um I think I am dpa should say that I
can levitate Wow trademarks after all
punchlines Schumer says yes see
Goodreads
[Music]
does anyone else love the title the girl
with the lower back tattoo um I love it
I think it's a good title submitted
you may not believe it but it's actually
me was Amy Schumer on Judge Judy today
if not that lady looks a lot like her I
guess you have to be an extra on crappy
TV after making crappy movies how about
who cares about me and it looks like
Angelina Jolie is right behind me in
this picture yeah I asked me an extra
round Judge Judy so I'm living my dreams
and don't get mad about that just go
live yours I took the steps to get in
the audience on Judge Judy can you take
the steps to do whatever it is you wanna
do haters does anyone else think my
awkward elementary school photo looks
like a brunette Amy Schumer finally
found my celebrity look-alike twinsies
I could see it I think I look like that
little chick yeah I guess I'm your
mother um is it just me or does young
Chris Jericho kind of look like Amy
Schumer well you know I have spoken to
Chris Jericho about this and I am so
flattered he's a beautiful man and I
would like to be considered a beautiful
man too more Yahoo Answers what do you
think of Amy Schumer playing a future
doctor who not only would she be the
first ever female doctor but the first
American to play the doctor they already
got a chick bra is Amy Schumer a real
person oh yeah I don't know why they
gave her a period hora
why did Amy Schumer choose to become a
comedian I think cuz I knew one day the
internet would be invented and I'd get
to read really useful comments some
really smart people why does he meet
Schumer talk about her vagina so much um
that's a good question if I talk about
it for three minutes of an hour it's not
so much you're gonna think about your
genitals
every time I pee I wipe that vagina
every time I have sex
someone's [ __ ] out vagina it's on my
mind what are you thinking about your
toes who are Amy Schumer's influences my
buzzy
the Muppets
if I like Amy Schumer what other current
comedians should I check out oh that's a
good question I would say I love chelsea
peretti
her special one of the Great's is on
Netflix
Jesse Klein Michelle wolf Rachel
Feinstein Nikki Glaser Natasha Leggero
Bridget Everett Margaret Cho Chelsea
Handler Sarah Silverman Judy gold
Jessica Kherson more nor more women a
comedy there are go look at them what
are the best inside Amy Schumer sketches
that's tough to answer I'm really proud
of my episode 12 Angry Men inside Amy
Schumer Wikipedia he was voted both
class clown and teachers worst nightmare
upon graduation in 1999 she also
attended the Hebrew school of central
synagogue of Nassau County this is all
true except they didn't include teachers
worst nightmare in the yearbook even
though he was voted teachers for a
signer because I think the other the
male version who wanted like lodged a
complaint like his parents didn't want
it into yearbook but I was proud in 2007
recorded live at Gotham Last Comic
Standing she recalled that she thought
of the episode is their big break yeah
when you're a stand-up or a performer
you think everything's your big break
you're like I got it this is it I'm
ready to sign my rich and famous papers
but I don't know it's 11 years later and
a lot of people just heard of me like a
year ago a lot of people never heard of
me so maybe I'll make it soon well
that's it I answered all your questions
on the Internet didn't know as much as
he thought about me did you I was
supposed to play red Sparrow